hi my name is stephen david and today
i'll be presenting some work from my lab
at oregon health and science university
that we've performed in collaboration
with the group of nima mezgarani at
columbia
and the question we're looking at today
is can deep learning produce a general
model of natural sound encoding by
auditory cortex
so what do i mean by encoding model
goal we have here is to understand how
the brain represents and computes
information about the sound that
encounters in the real world
so if i use an electrode to record
activity of neurons and auditory cortex
uh during the presentation of sound the
timing and magnitude of neural action
potentials that we record will reflect
some information about the sound that's
being presented
and when you use an encoding model what
you're trying to do
is replicate those computations so uh if
you provide the stimulus as an input to
the model
and it accurately can describe the
function of the system then it should
accurately be able to predict the output
of the neurons in response to those same
arbitrary sounds and so a good model is
one that sees a strong correspondence
between the predicted and actual
response
so there have been many advances in the
performance of encoding models but there
are still important gaps in our
knowledge and i'll be talking about some
new approaches that we've taken to this
problem today
and so developing more accurate encoding
models can be valuable for a number of
reasons in neuroscience at a very basic
level understanding central auditory
processing gives us a better
understanding of brain systems that can
be affected
by hearing loss
and the healthy auditory system can also
operate in very challenging and complex
acoustic environments and so if we have
a better understanding of how the
healthy brain works that can we can use
that to develop algorithms to have sort
of better performing hearing aids and
other auditory prosthetics
so given that
sort of big picture motivation
i'll be talking about three things today
first i'll motivate the use of this new
method deep neural networks to study
auditory coding
um then i'll show that these dnns uh in
fact perform better than standard widely
used encoding models for describing
activity in auditory cortex in
particular the time-varying activity
that's that occurs during presentation
of natural sounds
then finally i'll get it a challenging
question that that we encounter with
dnns which is uh how to interpret them
and so i'll spend some time showing that
that we've some methods we've developed
can be used to understand what it is
that these new models are doing
so as i mentioned there's been
substantial effort previously to build
encoding models in the auditory system
as well as other sensory systems and
in the auditory system the majority of
models are based on the idea of
spectrotemporal representations
so it's well established that in the
cochlea different populations of
receptors
respond to sounds at different
frequencies so
you can model this peripheral activity
as what's called the sound spectrogram
which is shown at the bottom here where
each row shows the sort of level of
activation in response to a sound at a
different frequency
and as you can see with this example
segment of speech natural sounds contain
complex spectral patterns and the job of
the auditory system is to recognize and
discriminate these patterns
that have different behavioral meanings
and so what you might call the standard
model for sound coding in in auditory
neurons is the linear non-linear
spectrotemporal receptive field often
called the strf
according to this model each neuron is
sensitive to stimuli in a particular
range of frequencies
and time lags this is illustrated here
by the heat map in the upper right
where red end areas indicate features
that increase spiking activity and blue
areas
when they're present indicate regions or
features that suppress spiking activity
using the strf the activity of a neuron
can be predicted by convolving this
linear filter with the sound spectrogram
the the output of the filter is followed
by what's called a static nonlinearity
which accounts for the fact that neurons
cannot produce negative action
potentials
and so this is used in the auditory
system but it's also used more widely
this general formulation is used more
widely across sensory systems and it's
often referred to as the linear
nonlinear ln model
and in the case of this neuron you can
see that the ln model is doing a pretty
good job so the the the panel at the
bottom shows the prediction of the ln
model in red
and
you can see that it corresponds pretty
well to the actual response that was
evoked in the neuron that was being
studied here which is shown in blue
so the ion sgrf is appealing uh because
it's relatively easy to understand
what's going on you can you can
look at the linear filter and you can
see what sound features are encoded by
the neuron and so this can be used for
instance to measure the best frequency
or the bandwidth of the
responses of the neurons and
using this approach uh a number of
studies have developed basic models of
what's going on in the auditory
periphery and how sounds are represented
at that stage of processing
however the problem uh with the ln model
becomes a little bit
bigger in more central areas especially
in auditory cortex because what happens
is these models don't predict everything
that the sounds actually produce
and so you can see that in this example
where again we have an strf
the color map is changed here but the
red and blue areas still indicate
excitatory and inhibitory tuning
and in this example we use the ln model
to predict the response to uh from a
different neuron to predict response to
a natural vocalization
and
in the in this uh
this data set the actual response is
plotted in gray and you can see that
there are periods of brief activation
associated with the onset and offset of
different sound features
and the model the ln model prediction is
overlaid in orange you can see in this
case it predicts the course activation
in response to different sound features
but it fails to predict this fine
temporal structure
and across auditory cortex the the
performance the accuracy of prediction
by the ln models is limited so we can
quantify prediction accuracy with the
correlation coefficient or r value
between the predicted and actual time
varying response
using this metric a maximum value of 1
indicates a perfect prediction
and
the r squared value indicates the
fraction of variance explained in the
neural response
and so in in one study after accounting
for a number of experimental factors
that can limit model performance uh we
found that the sort of maximal
performance on average across neurons
and auditory cortex
explains about 40 of response variants
and so there is room for improvement
over these models
and so this this problem is well known
and a number of efforts have been made
in past decades to develop models that
can perform better than the sgrf
and so i don't have time to go into all
the details of these models because
there are quite a few and they've taken
different approaches to extending the
strff either using ideas of different
biophysical properties present in the
system or using more general approaches
to expand beyond the linear
representations to various nonlinear
interactions that can be observed
between features
and so one
class of model that has grown uh
very popular recently in a number of
different applications is a new machine
learning approach uh called deep
learning or using deep neural networks
to model these responses and so these uh
these models have been developed and and
applied largely in the visual system so
far and with a little bit of work done
in the auditory system as well
and and the question here today is can
we use these approaches to describe the
activity of single units in in auditory
cortex
and so just to kind of point out again
and emphasize uh the kind of differences
between these different approaches to
modeling
now you can think of of the the ln model
as kind of being at one end or near one
end of the encoding model spectrum where
they're relatively simple and so while
they don't generalize uh to a large
number of stimuli very effectively they
are relatively easy to interpret
and these more complex models that have
been developed
are generally able to predict activity
in a wider range of circumstances but
they are also more complex to fit and
they require more data for fitting
and and these deep networks or sort of
the general class of artificial neural
networks lies a kind of
the extreme case where they have the
most generalizability but also are the
most complex
and with this complexity becomes a
challenge of interpretation and this is
something that is
particularly important for understanding
really the computations that are taking
place because these models are very
large and complex it's difficult to tell
exactly what information uh they're
they're representing in the neural
computations
so as i mentioned the dnns have been
applied uh most successfully and
extensively in the visual system
and this diagram here taken from the
work of yemen's and dicarlo uh
illustrates why it's very appealing as a
model for
sensory processing particularly in
sensory systems where there is an idea
that information is processed by a
hierarchical sequence of sensory areas
and so each dot here in these squares at
the top indicate a a a
cluster of uh simulated neurons each one
really is
effectively an uh
implementation of an ln model and so you
have these layers of of ln neurons each
with slightly different tuning that feed
into subsequent layers and and
what has been demonstrated uh just
empirically is that
if you have these large networks of of
uh linear nonlinear units that you can
account for very complex uh input output
relationships
and
uh what appears to also be uh useful
which is that the laminar structure the
processing that happens in each stage
seems to roughly parallel the
transformations in representation that
occur in the visual system
and so what do i mean by that well when
you record data from a very central
visual area in this case inferior
temporal cortex which is associated with
high level object recognition
what you find is that you can train a
dnn uh on a
computer vision task so to discriminate
different categories of images and if
you take the output of that
deep network you're able to
use a linear weighted combination of
those outputs to predict the activity of
a large number of neurons and inferior
temporal cortex
if you
simulate the activity of earlier layers
in the network
which which have responses that look
like uh earlier processed and staged in
the visual system they aren't able to
predict activity as well as you can see
in the performance comparison uh between
the uh early stage models of left and
the late stage models at right
so this shows that that especially in
central areas that the deep networks may
actually be very powerful and very
useful for explaining neural activity
but as i mentioned these are very
complex models with many parameters and
interpreting them has been challenging
so far what's been most successful is
this uh this approach which uh uses and
simulates the activity of the deep
network to try to determine
what you might call optimal stimuli for
the neurons so that you can you can
simulate a very strong response from the
network and you can back propagate the
effector back project the activity to
see what patterns what pattern or
patterns produce that activity
in the output
and this shows some examples again
getting this idea of
laminar hierarchy where you can back
project activity from either earlier
layers which are shown at left which
produce uh features that are related to
features that have been proposed to
occur at mid-level representations in
the visual system
and if you back protect the late stages
what you get are features that actually
look like visual objects uh that are uh
believed to be associated with activity
in in these central processing areas
dn analysis has not been applied as much
in the auditory system
but recently our collaborators used
the same general approach to study
encoding in human auditory cortex using
lfp data recorded from human epilepsy
patients undergoing monitoring for
treatment
and they used a a
similar architecture
of these layers of ln units as they're
illustrated in the bottom of this
picture here and what they found is that
when they compared performance to a
traditional ln model as is shown in the
scatter plot at the left that the
dnn performed consistently better both
in primary auditory cortex which is
heschel's gyrus or hg as well as in
superior temporal gyrus which is a
tertiary or higher higher order
representation
in human auditory cortex
and so the question we had today was can
we use the same modeling approach to
understand the activity of single units
in in the auditory cortex of
animals in a similar experimental
condition
so
the next question here is well can we
describe the time time-varying activity
of neurons in auditory cortex
briefly to describe our experimental
approach
we were presenting a large library of
natural sounds about 600 different
one-second samples as well as a
set of repeated sounds used for model
validation uh we presented these to
awake passively listening ferrets uh
using free field stimulation
contralateral to the recording site
and to collect single unit activity we
used laminar probes
6428 128
channel probes from ucla uh that uh
permitted uh simultaneous recording of
somewhere between 20 and 50 single units
in an experiment uh we could identify uh
lamina in different cortical fields
although we're not talking about the the
specific uh laminar patterns today
so in the ferret there's a hierarchy of
auditory areas that's roughly matched to
those that are primates
auditory stimuli come into the midbrain
they're processed
at several stages including the inferior
colliculus then pass through primary
auditory cortex or a1
and then some non-primary areas called
the belts uh and then ferrets it's
called area peg eventually that
information gets
switched or believed to guide behavioral
decisions
the data i'm talking about today was
recorded from two areas a1 which is
primary auditory cortex as well as this
belt region term peg
so we presented the same stimuli in each
experiment uh the same large library of
natural sounds and so as i mentioned we
get record from multiple neurons in one
experiment but then what we could also
do is construct a pseudo population by
combining the data from all of these
experiments into one large data set
that merged all of these different
recording sites and again we had
multiple sites from both a1 and the
secondary area bg
and the details of the models that we
tested we used a standard linear
nonlinear model as a baseline
and then we explored a number of
different dnn architectures
to kind of build on the previous results
we used a small dnn to analyze the
activity of of individual single units
that were recorded in the study and this
diagram here just shows roughly the
layout of the layers and arrangement of
the linear and non-linear units
the linear units were linear filters at
the input or dense uh dense units at
later layers
and the non-linearity in this case is
just a rectified uh
a linear rectifier uh which we chose for
reasons that may become apparent uh when
we talk about visualization in a few
slides
so in addition to this what we call a
single unit dnn we also developed what
we call a population model where we had
a similar architecture but instead of
just predicting the activity of a single
unit we had a large output layer that
that combined the previous layer with
different weights in order to predict
the activity of each of the neurons in
the population
and what we found is that this could
leverage the activity of a large number
of neurons into a common representation
that kind of took advantage of this
additional statistical power to get a
better prediction accuracy
and we used two different architectures
for the input layers
the what we call the one deconvolution
was mimicking in the classic strf model
the filters that i discussed already at
the input and then we also used a 2d
convolution which is more analogous to
the models that have been used in the
visual system and auditory system
previously
so
we evaluated a large number of models
that varied in the size and number of
layers i don't have time to go into all
the details today but actually as we
found the performance of these models
was very similar independent of the
architecture so those details may
actually not be so important
for fitting we used the neural encoding
model system library which was developed
as part of the brain initiative
that supports this project
and
the multiple fit using backpropagation
implemented in a tensorflow backend
so how does it do
well here's an example of the neuron
that i showed you previously uh where
the actual response shows uh the sort of
complex temporal dynamics uh when we
predict responses with this lm model it
fails to predict those responses so then
when we used a dnn model
again
implemented here this was using a 1d
convolution in the architectures that i
mentioned
it was able to capture quite a bit of
the detail in the in the temporal
response
as you can see in this purple plot
that's overlapped at the bottom
and across the population of neurons in
a primary auditory cortex we found that
there was a consistent improvement uh
for the dnn over the ln model so again
this is uh one architecture that
performed particularly well and the
black dots indicate neurons for which
the prediction accuracy was
significantly greater according to a
t-test for the the dnn over the ln model
one thing that i mentioned was striking
about this was that the
performance of the different dn
architectures was actually quite similar
so here two more example neurons again
plotted with the stimulus spectrogram at
the top and the simultaneous activity uh
of the uh
recorded in the two two panels at the
bottom gray shows the actual psth and
the performance of the ln model shown in
orange
the top panel you can see that again the
ln model isn't able to capture the fine
temporal structure of the response but
does get the overall
activation by the different stimuli
bottom panel shows a different case
where
the ln model was just unable to capture
it captured some fine temporal dynamics
but couldn't capture the relative
structure of the grey peaks for instance
that initial onset response it
underpredicted quite substantially
so when we used again this is the
the the the 1d convolution model that i
mentioned you can see that it does a
much better job capturing the responses
in both cases uh capturing both the fine
temporal structure in the top and those
large onsets that we see at the bottom
very striking though is when we tried
different architectures for instance
here's a 2d convolution we saw a nearly
identical results so a much different
configuration of artificial neurons but
we got a very similar prediction in the
end
and this is what we saw across the
population as well so at the left i'm
showing again the performance of the dnn
relative to ln model then the middle
panel just shows the performance of
these two different dnn architectures
and there are a few neurons where one
model would perform better than the
other but overall they're actually
predicting with very very similar
accuracy
and we can also
compare the
what we call the equivalence of these
different models by simply computing the
correlation coefficient between the
predicted responses of the different
models and so if we do that for the ln
model versus
one of the dna models that's plotted in
the orange histogram
you can see that the correlations are
generally
relatively low lower than one
but in the case of the two different dnn
architectures which are plotted in blue
you can see that they're significantly
higher and often very close to one which
indicates that they're that the
predictions are actually identical
so
as i mentioned we compared performance
of a large number of different
formulations of of the dnn architecture
and this pareto plot
shows the average performance the median
performance across all the neurons that
we recorded from an a1
and the x-axis shows the what we call
the complexity of the model which is
basically the number of free parameters
that were required per neuron and the
model fits
and what you might note uh
most prominently is that the model at
the bottom is the the performance of the
ln model which peaked at a course
five
and that didn't matter if we analyzed
each neuron separately or analyzed them
as a population model similar to the
population models that we're using for
the dnn
on the other hand all all the dnn models
performed quite similarly and
this includes again both the 1d
convolution as well as the 2d
convolution architecture and a number of
different variants that are that are
sort of schematized here
one thing to note is that the single
neuron dnn
achieved almost as good performance but
required generally a larger number of
parameters per neuron in order to
achieve the same level of performance
we performed the same analysis on the
data that we collected from non-primary
cortex or peg
and observe basically the same pattern
where the dnns performed similarly and
substantially better than uh than the ln
model
although in this case while everything
was was a little bit worse than an a1
the relative improvement was actually
greater for the dnns so where we saw
about 30 improvement in a1 we saw close
to a 40 or 45 percent improvement in peg
so another uh
interesting observation that we made
with the dnn models was that they were
able to generalize quite effectively to
new data
so as i mentioned we combine data from a
number of recording sites into a pooled
population in order to fit our models
but in a subsequent study we refit the
models excluding one site each time and
so we could train the entire model
then using this pre-trained model we
could fit the only the output layer
using data from this held out site
and when we did this
this is data from a1 what we found is
that the uh the different dnn models
performed nearly identically you can see
uh the the
strip plots compare performance of the
held out and the matched models
and you can see that the mean
performance was was nearly identical for
all the dnn architectures
but you'll note with the single unit dnn
model where we performed an analogous
transfer where we fit the model to one
cell and then fit the outputs to a new
cell
we saw that the held out models did much
worse than the original model showing
that by fitting these populations
together we're able to
analyze this quite effectively
so finally i wanted to briefly describe
the approaches that we're using to
understand what computations are being
captured by these models
so we can look at these models in their
entirety so this is an illustration of
one
dnn fit using the 1d convolution
approach and the top we see all the
filters which look like ln models and
you can see that they're connected
through these by these lines through a
sequence of layers and the color or the
brightness of the line indicates the
strength of that weight
so
you can see that there's a lot going on
and we can actually look at the
prediction of the model on the right
we're comparing the population
prediction uh to the actual response
that we saw in the bottom panel you can
see that there's very roughly a
correspondence of these the predicted
natural responses
but really understanding what's going on
here is tricky because there's just so
many there's so many free parameters and
so much going on
so what we did is use an approach that
was developed by our collaborators and
applied previously to the human lfp data
and that took advantage of a
relatively simple but important
observation of these networks which is
that at any given moment in time when
you're presenting stimuli a number of
the static non-linearities these
rectified linearities that i mentioned
earlier are below threshold so basically
the input is not
driving their outputs and so they're
effectively absent from the activity of
the of the of the network in this
particular state
and
so what we can do is we can essentially
remove those nodes and what's left is
the activated nodes which are all
performing just simple linear
transformations
and so the net activity of the of the
dnn at any given moment in time can
actually be collapsed into a single
linear filter which looks just like the
strf that we presented previously
uh but it's important to remember of
course that this is a dynamic strf so
the specific strf will change depending
on the particular stimulus that you're
presenting
and so just to get a very simple
intuition for this uh you can think of
the stimulus response relationship for
for a neural network or any nonlinear
system as this
this
in this cartoon example some some curve
that that's not flat right that it's
that's a nonlinear function
and if we look at some small regime of
stimulation for instance the yellow or
the blue areas here
the performance within that regime is
can be approximated using a line
and so what we're doing when we compute
a dstrf is effectively fitting this
locally linear model to the activity in
this sort of restricted sensory context
and so what does that look like with
with the data that we have so here's
that first example that i showed you and
there's there's quite a bit going on
here uh but what you might recognize at
the top is the stimulus and then the
prediction of the ln model and then the
dnn model in purple
and what i'm showing in the bottom row
are dynamic strfs that work fit
again using at each point in time that's
indicated by those dashed red lines
and so what you might notice is that uh
the pattern of activation the the area
the blue the red and blue areas that
indicate excitatory inhibitory tuning
are changing from moment to moment
and
so what this illustrates is that
while the ln strf shows a single pattern
of activation that actually this neuron
is responding to different
spectrogeneral patterns at different
points in time
but if you look carefully at this data
what you'll see is that it's not
completely random so the dsgrfs are
changing but they're actually changing
in somewhat repeatable ways and so you
can see that by performing a principal
component analysis or pca on the dsgrs
and then the first three pcs are shown
at the bottom here and what they show
is that there is a relatively
small set of features that explain the
variations that we're seeing in the
dsgrf across time
so
uh we use this dstrf analysis and then
perform pca on the cells in our in our
uh
data set and here are just ten examples
showing uh at the top the first pc the
largest pc and then the bottom two rows
show the second and third pcs for those
same neurons
and again there's a lot to look at here
and this is an area that we're actively
exploring to try to understand what
information is captured by these neurons
but just very roughly one thing you
might notice is that
the
relative uh contribution of these pcs
can vary from from neuron to neuron so
the brightness of the of the
the dstrf indicates the relative
variance explained in the in the total
dstrf by each principal component
and if we compute that value per neuron
what we see is that as expected with pca
the first component is always the
largest but the relative magnitude of
that component varies substantially from
cell to cell
and so one thing that you can predict is
that uh
that these more complex spaces that are
captured that require a larger number of
principal components to capture are
going to correspond to neurons that
showed a greater benefit of this more
complex dnn model and in fact that's the
case so at the right here we're plotting
the
fraction of variance explained by the
first principal component in the dstrf
against the relative improvement so the
difference between prediction
performance for the dnn and the ln model
and what you found what you find is that
for the cells that show the greatest
performance increase in performance at
right the relative fraction explained by
the first pc is smaller
and so indeed these more complex dynamic
strfs correspond to cells where the dnn
model is showing the greatest
improvement
and so we're now using this approach to
analyze data from secondary cortex as
well but unfortunately i don't have time
to get into that today
so just briefly to recap what i talked
about today uh first
what we have shown is that deep neural
networks or dnns can account for
time-varying activity of single neurons
and auditory cortex
consistently and often substantially
better than standard linear nonlinear
models
uh what was uh also quite striking is
that the performance of the dnns did not
depend on the details of the
architecture and so we could try a use a
large number of different formulations
and get very similar results
however with this population model one
exciting thing that we observed was that
we were able to use these preset models
to new data sets and that opens up a
number of possibilities where we may be
able to use them to analyze data from
experiments where the amount of data is
often limited for instance uh in
behavioral studies where
the number of trials that you can get in
a particular behavioral condition is
often limited and it's often been
difficult to use encoding model analysis
for those types of studies
and finally we we're using this
method
of dynamic strf measurement to describe
the space or the range of
spectrotemporal patterns that describe
tuning
and we can use this as a measure of
complexity
to compare representations in different
brain areas
so with that i wanted to make sure to
thank uh everyone who contributed to
this project jacob pennington is a
student in my lab who really did the
bulk of the analysis and modeling
uh also of course nima mez gharani and
manua kashishian at colombia were
instrumental in developing these methods
in particular the dstrf analysis
i also wanted to mention a couple
students in my lab matteo lopez espeo
and charlie heller who are instrumental
in collecting the data that we analyzed
here
also the funding from the brain
initiative in particular for this
project
i did want to mention that the the all
the software that we use for this
analysis is available as part of the
neural encoding model system or nems
that's available on github so please
feel free to contact me if you have any
questions about that
and finally thank you for listening